okay I've got a game request started oh
I know I got a game yeah let's let's
start this 15-minute game let's go let's
go for for a change
five yeah let's go for Lopez and see
what variation is coming up with the
very old-fashioned Steinitz variation
well old-fashioned also means that I
don't have a really good idea here what
are they I think defaults are normal
move but I never looked at this
I think it's normal now to to catch on
c6 with the bishop yeah this is unusual
would be normal to take with the pawn
and rely on the two bishops the images
capture this thing and now it's got some
some weaknesses on the Queen side it's
up but it's not nothing serious yet of
course
you know
let's see how you watch it
this looks somewhat weird to me to go
for g6 here thinking about in 2d form
with the idea to well the Queen has got
an interesting ask where on c4 where it
would take c6 and Queenie forward gain a
tempo and it's I don't know it's
questionable if you can simply play
Knight f6 because Bishop g5 looks a bit
down a bit fishy I think or black let's
say Queen d4 Knight f6 Bishop g5 Bishop
g7 hmm I could play e5 you do you takes
Queen takes Queen e7 yeah white should
be you should be somewhat better in this
position it's not it's not overwhelming
that's a Queeny Queeny for Knight f6
Bishop g5 Bishop g7 do I have something
else
of course Queen C for the Queen d7
should be you should be okay
yeah maybe cannot really really punish
this so it's looking weird still okay
I'm thinking about nine f6 Bishop g5
Bishop g7 then this e5 line should be
somewhat better for wide okay it doesn't
it doesn't play it but Queen c4 looks a
bit embarrassing now as c6 um it's not
so easily covered maybe he can play
queer knight Knight to e7 but it's um I
don't know that looks strange
so this position of the Queen here maybe
Bishop teaching with the idea to to go
to c3 and and use this configuration on
the diagonal here let's say Bishop d2
I cannot take Bishop c3 just picks up
the rook and c3 also covers a a 1 so
Bishop d2 what what else should he
should he play the d5 maybe or something
that I have Q&A forum yeah and he also
cannot develop with Pacific Bishop g7
Bishop c3 is just terrible
maybe you should play something like we
need six or something 26 years
this looks like a decent move okay
Queenie for do I take first on d5 I
don't want to really go into EDC D 27 or
something it looks
I don't know unnecessary let's say just
clean air for this keeps the bishop c3
c3 threat live yeah so now there's more
than one one good idea play pawn to c3 I
could all kinds of things are possible
if five is also also an idea okay let's
let's let's check if I've could clean if
he takes it I have I've got rook e1 and
twin c6 this is thread actually because
the Ruby one pins the 927 so he 525 rook
e1 and for instance if he I don't know
goes to somewhere on the fifth rank I
can take this six but it can go to be 5
or d5 yeah other idea would be c3 of
course you cannot take cannot play c5
also night a three to c4 it's an
attractive idea also interesting bishop
before an honor to take on his seven if
he plays Bishop three seven
yeah very very good possibilities here
some just not so easy to decide what's
the best yeah well okay let's try this
one it was hard to tell what what's the
best really among all this attractive
moves
yeah the main point up it should be four
causes some if you take if you play some
Bishop to g7 which that's the most
natural move I can play just true for it
just takes on e7 or completely v e5
Queen e6 then then take on e7
King takes hmm yeah that's a very bad
position just just like that the pieces
don't have a lot of possibilities here
like flex pieces this whole setup with
but ninety seven ninety nine oh six or
seven just just very much lacking in
harmony
Wow not sure the Queen B five could be
it could be his idea
yeah
okay let's let's go see-through now
you still cannot take on tc3 of course
and I don't see a good move let's say
queen bee five I can I can just exchange
it and take me a deform with a very nice
extra part yeah maybe this was some
relatively speaking the best
okay
you two take this so let's check out
what some what's the most precise here
gets D 5 D 5 immediately
I would have liked to to preserve this
pair yonder for me forward no no cannot
really cover default provocative one but
rook da then I'm forced to move this
anyway
most likely yeah okay
okay let's um maybe just stroke fd1 yeah
I need to get rid of this night
I'm not sure what he's thinking about
doesn't seem to be much else and then
that'd be five well you can can give
this check on e2 but King have one night
f4 and I don't know what's an i doing on
that fall doesn't doesn't have any good
targets class there so just nine-to-five
yeah this also covers some c7 a bit
which is also weakness yeah most likely
black belong at some point try to break
the center of with f5 to some some
active to make the play possible but on
f5 I always have some ideas like night
to see a c5 and 6 and so on I can just
play rock c1
okay let's say yeah this doesn't doesn't
lead to much I was thinking about Roxy
five but we can just look back 26 let's
cover a uniform prophylactically maybe
breaking f 2 e 3 so just good moves to
to strengthen the position ok it's an
interesting question now if you really
AM threatened some f5 or something yeah
I'm ok let's make sure that f5 is not
possible immediately going to e6 [ __ ]
could with zebra 2 to play this
and I need to watch a bit the clock time
playing this slowly as usual okay five
minutes are still plenty but okay just
six is just a non move it doesn't do
anything
okay
and well I five would be a just a great
square for the knight should try to get
the night where five really this would
be great but
just trying to probe this weaknesses
also if we would exchange 9cm I think it
would ease my task considerably
yeah sure not deform yeah it should be a
simple simple way to play the position
he cannot really am
avoid the exchange now 96 I just
captured c7 and if he exchanges then
I've got very simple play against his
happen
the b5 not always protected c7 very
reliably some now it should be should be
easy to two tickets rook c6 roopd to see
form black okay now he will never have
any counter play as always thinking
about f5 at some point so very likely
that it is never played will would be
the only slightly active idea well now
just rope DC for neck smooth and c7 less
attacked twice if you cover those group
a 7 I have d6 so the only way to to
protect c7 would have been I think rook
to e7 and one Luke 287 well both roofs
protecting from the 7th which is passive
of course and most likely also losing in
the long run but what this is simple I
think can just play Roxy 46 and it's
over
yeah he's trying to figure out how to
how to keeps his sudden that won't be
possible
but while he takes his time a mind might
answer a couple of questions that were
post in response to yesterday's videos
one or two guys asked him why why the
International master title is not shown
here on the ICC the other thing is that
I don't don't have the title yet because
this is really a process that involves a
bit of paperwork and it took quite some
weeks to get the papers to to feed a and
so on and basically it so that this
title only awarded I think two or three
times a year maybe four times a year on
various occasions where feeder officials
meet and so on I'm not so sure about
about the details there so what what it
comes to is that I made the final norm
for the title um beginning of October
and the last feed a meeting for titles
and other issues was in October so this
was just too short too short and a
distance of time to to get other the
paperwork there so it's um it will be
done I think the first week of February
so I think in four and four or five
weeks I'll get I get the title finally
and then it will also appear on on ICC
um not sure what else was asked yes um
some person asked me about the sounds
during the video if I'm still smoking or
what I'm but whatever has smoking
I switched from from normal tobacco
cigarettes to this electric electronic
cigarettes which use those liquid that's
that is I don't know if I hate it this
is the right word and I guess this sound
the sound somewhat strange on the
microphone I think maybe it sounds like
I don't know like I'm smoking something
not entirely illegal or something but
it's it's just this kind of electronic
cigarette
I guess it's I know I figured that's
less harmful than the in the tobacco
ones and maybe a stop too as a first
step to to quit completely I'm quite
happy that I'm I'm this form to month
without tobacco cigarette okay
resigned okay I resigned yeah let's have
a quick recap recap of the game sorry I
think everything was was quite okay
until here I'm not sure on g6
looks strange to me still I think just
Knight f6 or not f6 we should be seven
and so on and but here you should I
should I think just simply play Knight
f6 shouldn't be shouldn't be that bad oh
the calm the computer is already very
much in whites failure are interesting
on Knight f6 the computer suggestion is
not not Bishop g5 but but rupee one or
Queen c3 our Queen c3 is also another
bad idea
didn't see this one yeah let's say
Knight f6 Queen c3 and then it's
difficult for him to protect c6 he
actually a computer actually suggests
play rook b8 then so Knight f6 Queen CC
ruby aid and I can well just take on c6
if I'm if I don't find anything better
yeah then g6 really was was a mistake
yeah it looked it looked really fishy to
me let's say okay Queen f6 and this this
should be already very nice for white
how come also wants to play Bishop d2
okay then it shouldn't be that bad and
now Queenie six yes also the computer
suggestion and it should be somewhat
better for white but maybe it's it's not
not anything decisive but this is
certainly just good for white computer
versus played Bishop z3 yeah it's also
great great for white let's say DC for
Bishop f6 and then you pick up c4 with
92 we have this is a technical solution
but this is also terrible I think this
should be should be very good for white
computer actually drops down to 0.5 here
Bishop g7 it wants to play Knight c3
okay but on Bishop g7 I would have
played Bishop z3 of course then d4
Bishop b4 is just better for white from
the structural point of view I'm not
sure what is the computer subjection to
Bishop c3 no idea also I'm only got two
stock fish yeah not two not Houdini but
stock fish is not that bad either
strange wood to me to to look more
closely here but this is already
well rainy terrible yeah another
computer actually wants to play green b5
as well
I thought this is about the only move to
to continue the game
yeah okay this was pretty pretty
straightforward win okay let's start
start a new game